for the first time benchmark US oil
prices have crashed into negative
territory meaning producers are now
paying buyers to take it away in a
massive one-day drop
West Texas Intermediate fell from about
17 point $50 a barrel to below zero it
was trading at around $60 a barrel at
the start of the year
global demand has plummeted because of
the coronavirus related lockdowns and
travel who sticks restrictions and fears
over a lack of storage space this is
despite continous attempts to counter
the havoc in global energy markets well
earlier this month Russia and Saudi
Arabia agreed to an unprecedented cut an
output of almost 10 million barrels a
day to try to boost virus hit markets
anishka Padilla's director of energy at
policy advisers an independent research
provider in the oil and gas industry he
joins me now by Skype from London it
really was a perfect storm we knew of
the tensions within the OPEC the
extended OPEC group they only came to a
solution just over a week ago and of
course it's the lack of demand how I
guess how tenuous a situation are we
finding ourselves in now good evening
clearly unprecedented times at the
moment in terms of the wider global
market for the oil market as well I
think we're in a situation that we've
never seen before in in there especially
at the moment we're having massive
impacts to global demand growth probably
around 30 odd million barrels a day of
demand being impacted globally about a
third of global supply and that combined
with currently no OPEC cuts being in
place actually the OPEC deal that broke
down this is the aftermath of that the
the taps being opened means that you've
just got a huge amount of supply coming
on to the market at the time when demand
is completely down in the dumps so
that's that's the fundamentals and
there's a further impact that the
there's an
once that the WTI contract is expiring
today so the people that own those
contracts are scrambling to actually get
rid of that crude now because they're
worried that when it's produced in May
that they'll be nowhere to store that
crew they'll be nowhere to take it
because storage is filling up obviously
part of the lack of demand I mean all of
it because of the corona virus outbreak
but already we're seeing countries that
are slowly lifting a lot of their
restrictions which will ever have an
impact on the use of oil how much time
do you think there is before that begins
to happen for some breathing space so
when it comes to storage of oil
something there's there's two effects in
terms of demand there is the temporary
effect that we're seeing at the moment
which is the predominant effect so the
people being stuck at home unable to
drive you've got big falls in gasoline
demand there's a lack of demand for
products so you've got a lack of you've
got a falling diesel demand and then
there's not a lot of light taking place
so there's a huge amount that has been
soft at the moment a lot of that demand
will come back and that will come back
slowly as the as lockdown is eased there
will be some law larger longer-term
legacy effects the weaker economy for
example GDP growth is very correlated
world demand growth that you'll you'll
start to see continuing for the
remainder of the year I think the more
important thing is from a supply
perspective what you'll also see is that
some of this supply that comes off the
market won't come back on the market
again so demand there is a big negative
impact at the moment but eventually
demand will recover over the course of
the next 12 to 18 months however some of
that supply that comes off the market in
places like the u.s. wells the economic
at the moment a lot of those won't come
back online which is why when you look
at the futures price you see futures
pricing significantly higher than
than where you are even next month the
historic sort of news line right now is
that the benchmark US oil prices crashed
into negative territory so that's the
benchmark US oil price what is the
situation looking like elsewhere in the
world yes so the oil price is very all
around the world they very for reasons
of the quality of the crude so how
desirable that crude is also the
location so in the u.s. at the moment
there's clearly a lot more supply than
there is demand and storage if you look
at the probably more widely traded
benchmark Brent you know that's still
trading in the 20s it's a very low price
in in historical terms but it's a it's
it's still a reasonable oil price so I
you know I think that that's more
reflective of where supply and demand
are coming out at the moment
but needless to say I think oil prices
are going to stay very weak for the next
month or two until you see the impact of
both demand recovering as restrictions
lifted but also we've got the cards to
come from the OPEC plus agreement
they'll come from start to come through
in May and that that should help ease
some of this supply as well was an
element of this predictable or were you
also surprised to see the benchmark US
oil price crash quite the way it has
well I think has certainly taken people
by surprise I think there's been some
talk out there of oil prices in certain
region there are certain regions have
turned negative you're places like
Canada places where the oil quality is
low in there's very little storage of
certain grains of crude had to negative
already now I think that this is due to
a combination of the expiry is coming up
today so it's limited volumes it's low
liquidity but it's on a benchmark crude
so it grabs all the headlines now the
the actual physical volumes are crude
being traded at this price are pretty
low and as I say that the more widely
traded benchmark Brent
still in the twenties anishka Padilla
director of energy at policy advisers
sir thank you for sharing your views
with us and now let's cross to our White
House correspondent Kimberly halket
Kimberly the White House of course will
be watching all of this very closely
what more can you tell us about any
reaction that we might have had yeah the
White House has not officially reacted
to this news it has been breaking rather
dramatically though here in the US in
the last hour or so but I can tell you
that this is not the news that the
president wants to hear because the
president even some of his critics we're
touting what they believed was his
success just a week or so ago in sort of
scoring this deal if you will to try and
tamp down this oversupply in the markets
there was that conference call between
the US president the Russian leader the
Saudi Crown Prince where they thought
that they had been able to cut
production rather significantly and deal
with this oversupply the US president
for his part had at one point even
looked at this as an issue of national
security for the United States so the
feeling was that everything was going
well this was enough to calm the markets
this was going to help the energy
industry and also that this was going to
help the US economy of course we've seen
all of that change in just the last few
hours and that of course is going to
make the US president rather nervous and
just adding to the concerns for this
White House because it has been trying
very hard to get the economy reopened as
a result of the global pandemic even
starting the first phases of lifting
some of the social distancing that has
taken place in terms of stay-at-home
orders this is not the news that the
president is hoping to hear he had
really looked at May 1st as a key target
date for trying to reopen the economy
and we know that in terms of this
oversupply that exists when it comes to
capacity which is what is really
triggering the nervousness in the
markets that we hear that that early
next month is that target date when
those sort of supply will hit the limits
and that is going to be a real problem
for a president who is trying to reopen
the economy in the u.s. at the very same
time absolutely any can believe while
all of that is going on there's also an
going scrutiny
the coronavirus testing in the u.s.
because the death toll there of course
keeps rising yeah the death toll
according to the numbers and I was just
checking the right before we came on in
terms of infections we have 766
thousands in the United States the
deaths topping 40,000 in the United
States and of course that is continuing
but as we talked about the economy we
talked about new infections the problem
is here's what the governors are telling
this White House we don't have enough
tests in order to feel even confident
about reopening our economy the White
House for its part is insisting look at
we're getting you we're getting you the
tests that you need the infrastructure
is being built it's sort of happening in
real time
we should have five million tests by the
end of this month but you do the math
there are 330 million plus people in
this country you're trying to get
everyone back to work and you've only
got five million tests by the end of the
month that's a significant shortage of
diagnostic tests so what we see is the
vice president talking to some of the
governors today trying to assure them
that there will be an increase in
capacity the defense production act is
being put in place to try and get up to
20 million test tests but again looking
at the math 20 million three hundred
thirty million people a significant
shortfall so this is really just adding
to the problems for this White House
they're gonna have to answer for them
the briefing 21 GMT where they're going
to be talking about tests but they're
also gonna be talking about the
instability in the oil markets as they
try to deal with this and the reopening
of the economy a high priority for this
president absolutely we will of course
be taking that news conference live here
on al-jazeera will be interesting to see
what the president says about all of
these issues